what i want to do in this video is
discuss what it means to be a metal or
metallic nature so first let's just
think about the the metals that we
encounter in everyday life or based on
our experience the things that we
associate with being a metal
so the elements that really jump out at
us at metals we always refer to hey
that's a metal or that's metallic are
things like iron
iron
or
nickel
or copper
or
silver
or gold or aluminum or at least for me
these are the ones that immediately pop
out so hey these are i've i've seen
these things before and i they all feel
like metals to me but i'll think about
what is what what's true about these
things and as we'll see many other
elements on the periodic table that give
them this metallic nature what do we
associate with having a metallic nature
well one is that these things can be
shiny
these things tend to be
shiny that there's kind of a gloss when
light shines on it they're not just kind
of a matte color they they look metallic
literally that's sometimes the word
that's used for it it has a metallic
shininess to it another thing that we
associate with is they tend to be they
tend to be fairly dense if i take a
metal a block of a metal and if i drop
it into water i imagine that sinking
that it's not floating on top of the
water
we also imagine them having a very high
melting point that they tend to be solid
at room temperature
solid at room
room temperature and as we'll see this
is true of all metals except for one of
them which is mercury which is shiny but
at room temperature as you might be
familiar is in its liquid in its liquid
form now the other things that i
associate with a metal is that i can
make things out of them pretty i can
bend them and shape them in different
ways if i think of aluminum foil i can
bend it it's not going to it's not just
going to crack i can brand it and print
to different shapes even things like
iron it might take a lot of pressure to
do it but they're bendable they're
malleable and definitely you know things
like gold and silver and copper you can
actually mold into different types of
jewelry if you if you put pressure on it
it's more likely to bend than crack and
just kind of shear off so let's put
malleability they're malleable
malleable and the other thing that i
associate with metals is that they
conduct electricity well
conduct
conduct electricity a place that you'll
see metal in your life is if you open up
your electronics you'll see wires that
might be made out of copper or you might
have components that are made out of
other metals like gold or silver or
whatever else
so let's given that you know this is
these are some of the properties that we
associate with metals let's think about
what's happening at the atomic level to
give
these elements this these properties
the way i think about it let's just a
minute let's just go with copper for a
second let's just imagine a block of
commer copper at the atomic level so
let's say this is one copper nucleus
right over there and it has its sea of
electrons it has its sea of electrons
just like not in that sea of electrons
it has all of its electrons and the
various orbitals we'll talk about sea of
electrons in a second but this is kind
of its cloud of electrons i should say
so this is electron cloud so the
electrons are just jumping around in
this cloud it's really a probability
density
or there's kind of a certain probability
that could be at any point in that cloud
and so let's imagine a big solid piece
of copper
so you would have a bunch of these
you would have a bunch of these all
together
all forming
the solid
and what allows metals to
be malleable to do things like conduct
electrons or conduct electricity which
is the movement of electrons is
essentially for the for for that they're
very willing to share electrons with
each other by sharing electrons so you
can imagine this is one copper atom
that's another let's say they're sharing
some electrons that's what allows the
electricity or this flow of electrons to
happen if these electrons are loosely
bound then if you put a potential
difference a voltage let's say that you
put a potential difference so that this
side is more negative and then this side
is more positive then the electrons are
going to want to get away from the
negative charge move towards the
positive charge and if they're
relatively freely bound they can kind of
move from one cloud to the next and you
kind of end up having what's often
called a c of electrons let me write
that down you have a c
of electrons
of electrons which makes which would
make this conductive and that's why you
see so much wire made out of copper and
the sea of electrons is also what makes
it malleable if someone were to put if
someone you know on this side would have
put a lot of pressure this way and on
that side put a lot of pressure that way
things that are rigid would just kind of
crack and break
right would just break right over there
but because you have the sea of
electrons it allows it to be malleable
this part might just bend down a little
bit that part might bend up but they're
not going to the metallic bond is not
going to break
and so given that this metallic nature
really comes from the willingness of
these atoms to share electrons with each
other to create the sea of electrons i
encourage you to pause this video and
think about which which atoms on the
periodic table which elements are more
likely to do that to share electrons
with others and with each other and
really this is the same principle that
we thought about ionization energy and
electronegativity so
pause the video
so i'm assuming you've you've had a go
at it
so which elect the which elements are
most likely to share electrons well
we've already seen that if we're on the
left side of the periodic table of
elements group one for example they only
have one valence electron it would be
very hard for them to
to get enough electrons to complete that
outer shell and if they get rid of that
one valence electron they can go to a
more stable state so they really want to
give away electrons and the ones over
here they're so close if we're talking
about the if we talk about the halogens
they're one electron away from
completing their outer shell they're
greedy they want to hog these electrons
they tend to be electronegative the
noble gases they're done they definitely
don't want to share electrons with
anyone they're kind of in a very stable
state
now the other thing that we've talked
about is as we go down a group our
our our atoms are getting larger and
larger and larger so the outermost that
55th electron in cesium is much more
loosely bound because it's further away
than the say the third electron in
lithium so just as we saw as the
elements in this bottom left have a very
low ionization energy it's very it
doesn't take much energy to remove an
electron from them these are the ones
that are most likely to share electrons
and these actually have the highest
metallic nature
so high
high
metallic
high metallic nature
and the ones on the top right
these are going to be the opposite
they're very unlikely to share electrons
these are very electronegative they have
a very high ionization energy they have
a low
metallic nature
so i can imagine some things are popping
into your brain at this point you know
we started thinking of the the the
elements that in our everyday life we
associate with with
metals
but what i'm saying is that these things
over here have an even higher metallic
nature but what about something like
calcium you know every day when i
imagined when i typically or when a lot
of people imagine calcium they think of
kind of a chalky a white chalky
substance very rigid not very malleable
not very good not very shiny not very
good at conducting electricity i mean
based on what i just told you this would
have a higher metallic nature than
something like aluminum we have to
remind yourself is that that what you
see is not actually pure calcium that
that that kind of chalky thing that's
calcium carbonate pure calcium actually
this is actually a picture of pure
calcium and it is shiny it does have
these metallic properties so the general
trend here is that all of these this is
very high metallic nature and these are
very low metallic nature which also
makes you probably realize wow most of
the periodic table
is a metal of some form if aluminum is a
metal and all of these things have a
higher have a higher metallic nature
than all of this stuff
all of this stuff are metals and that is
the case the s block the d block the f
block these are all metals and then
about a good chunk of the p block a good
chunk of the p block are considered
metals and then these are kind of these
are kind of sometimes referred to as
metalloids and then this only this
section of the periodic table
is not considered a metal that makes
sense the noble gases they are gases
they don't they are not very reactive
they don't bond so they don't form kind
of a structure that can even do this
type of thing and these other ones over
here even you know carbon when it is it
formed a lattice it does not conduct
electricity well it's not so it tends to
not be so malleable if you think about
something like a diamond or if you think
about well a diamond might be the best
example of that so anyway hopefully this
gives you a sense of
metallic nature and the trends in the
periodic table high metallic nature and
as you go to the top right lower and
lower metallic nature